die provinz dai kundi in
zentralafghanistan
traditionelle siedlungsgebiet der
schiitischen hazara seit kurzem werden
sie von den taliban vertrieben zugunsten
paschtunischer bauern per dekret drohen
die neuen machthaber mit gewalt und tod
diese männer berichten neue
gerechtigkeit wir sind hier 300 familie
die taliban haben uns neun tage zeit
gegeben um unsere häuser zu verlassen
wir wollten verhandeln aber die taliban
haben geantwortet verschwindet einfach
sonst werdet ihr getötet über 1000
familien wurden bereits vertrieben kurz
vor dem winter sind sie der kälte
schutzlos ausgeliefert schon ende des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts wurden die
hazara opfer eines genozids
für die hazara sieht es besonders
schlecht aus bei ihnen handelt es sich
um die volksgruppe die seit der
machtergreifung der taliban am meisten
verloren hat
sie ist vollständig aus dem politischen
raum ausgeschlossen worden genau wie aus
dem kulturellen
und sie haben keinen einfluss mehr
innerhalb der taliban administration
[Musik]
die provinz bamian einige hundert
kilometer weiter östlich
hier standen bis 1998 die welt-
berühmten steinernen buddha statuen
bevor sie von den taliban gesprengt
worden vor allem die hier siedelnden
hazara helfen später beim wiederaufbau
wegen ihrer religion und rassistische
vorbehalte werden sie seit jahrhunderten
von sunnitischen paschtunen
diskriminiert verfolgt und ermordet
mutter beim er sei als jugendlicher vor
den taliban nach deutschland wurde
steinmetz und kehrte immer wie in seiner
heimat
für meine kultur um eine land eng
gefasst machen ich wurde nicht ein in
afghanistan verlassen und vergessen ich
wollte einfach meine heimat wider
ja was ich kann gelernt und erfahrung
einfach irgendwie beim aufbauen meine
heimat unterstützen
die gesteinsbrocken der gesprengten
bruders haben wirs rücken ruiniert heute
fährt er taxi in münchen und versucht
den menschen seiner heimat zu helfen in
dai kundi hat er ein geburtshaus
gegründet
2001 hat taliban bei uns in dai kundi
hand immer für allzu tat viele junge
leute gesucht
ich war damals 15 jahre alt dann habe
ich eigentlich geklickt und
dann habe ich meine eltern hat gesagt
ich will nicht dass mein sohn für
taliban kämpfen und deshalb
[Musik]
bis heute wird die kultur der aus der
mongolei eingewanderten
persischsprachigen ethnie im westen kaum
bekannt mit einer ausstellung seiner
fotos im münchner gasteig will merr sei
ihr ein gesicht geben wenn ihr hauptziel
wortes nicht andere seite von
afghanistan schöne seite von afghanistan
zeigen also nicht nur negativ krieg oder
so ich wollte einfach nur leute zeigen
afghanistan hat auch kultur geschichte
und viele tolle andere sache her die
muss man auch mich vergessen
[Musik]
das ist eine hazara frau in barmen die
traditionelle kleidung zum glück in
bamian die frauen dürfte schule gehen
ausbildung machen universität der so
studieren und einfach in gesellschaft
frei
wählen zum beispiel arbeiten gehen geld
verdienen und kämpfen also für ihr recht
zur ikone der weiblichen
selbstbestimmung wurde unter den hazara
die hämatologen und politikerin habiba
sarah die als erste frau afghanistans
wurde sie unter präsident hamid karsai
zur gouverneurin ernannt und war
maßgeblich an der förderung der
frauenrechte beteiligt
inzwischen ist auch sie ins ausland
geflohen
schon vor der machtübernahme hatten
radikale islamisten zahlreiche attentate
gegen die hazara vergibt
ihre ziele waren vor allem mädchen
schulen und sogar eine
entbindungsstation
[Musik]
sarah akbar kam 2013 als studentin aus
kabul nach deutschland wo sie als
berufsberaterin in der flüchtlingshilfe
arbeitete dass die radikalislamisten vor
allem hazara mädchen und frauen ins
visier nehmen hat für sie nur einen
grund
also ich bin der meinung wenn eine frau
ist der haupt kern der familie und alles
stammt von eine frau von einer mutter
wenn eine mutter gut ausgebildet ist
stark ist dann erzählt auf starke kinder
und das wissen sie auch was können die
mädchen die erst in schüler zur schule
gehen was haben sie mit politik zu tun
dass sie vor ein match schüler dieser
bomben attac gemacht haben und über 180
menschen ums leben gekommen sind also
dahinter
statt nur ein wahnsinnig geil
ein essen von hazara familien in münchen
die stimmung ist gedämpft auch hier hat
man von den vertreibungen gehört viele
verwandte und freunde aber können
afghanistan nicht verlassen unter den
westlichen schutzmächte war ihre kultur
aufgeblüht jetzt fühlen sie sich von
ihnen im stich gelassen
das regionalmächte wie pakistan und der
iran sich mit russland und china auf ein
gemeinsames vorgehen zum schutz der
hazara vor den taliban einigen gilt als
unwahrscheinlich
so müssen sie ihr schicksal wieder
einmal selbst in die hand nehmen
[Musik]